I'm just a funny person like I'm really
like outspoken I
like to think I'm funny
say public
taken serious
ly I I think that you know if it's meant
to be it's meant to be he's out there
somewhere and he would appreciate who
I'm doing do you think you're broke do
you think I broke fat guy I should say
oh if it's meant to be women will like
me or do you think he should improve I
personally would definitely improve but
okay yeah okay so if you're if your
mindset is off do you think if you say
it's meant if it's meant to be it's
meant to be or do we try to improve
always try to improve so so how do we
improve as women if we can't even admit
there's a problem